hi I'm Christopher hin and today we're
going to talk about everything comes
from showman part two last time we
talked about transitioning showman into
the heoi position and what if they come
around uh now we'll talk about uh
transitioning to the EDI position and
what comes off of the EDI position and
why that is um this is probably not
going to be a tragically long video um
there will be three videos in this
series though um talking about all the
different parts but I'm going to get
Josh over here right now we're going to
talk about what happens from the edme
position
[Music]
Josh did you see I snapped on that one I
don't know it's also going to be jarring
from the beginning because in the I
didn't
but uh so aside from my bizarre pointing
habit here uh so Josh and I are going to
talk today about um shui how everything
comes from shanci and we'll talk about
the eating me position so just to recap
real quick in the last video series we
talked about using sore and getting the
heo me position and then his natural
tendency to want to come around and get
me and then how I can atim in that and
that leads us to G nag and all kinds of
other stuff uh can come from that so
that video is the first part of this
okay second part is EDI which is going
to be my next major go-to in this right
so meaning that I'm like this and I want
to shoot EDI right so two real ideas I'm
going to have from this is I'm going to
want to either continue to drive forward
or to sweep so the moari and see what's
behind me and and whatever different
actions I'm taking right okay now my
basic idea is simply the EDI tyoo which
is this I check check and I come in now
an interesting thing about this is let's
go to this side so we can get the front
camera if I don't check that elbow and I
come in and Josh just bends his arm I
walk into his elbow essentially right so
meaning if he just tried just a little
bit as I just walk through here CL he's
going to clock me in the head so I have
to check that elbow as I come through
right now when I check that elbow here
this gives me the potential for EO right
so all of our EOS now it's switch back
so so I come in here and he bends that
elbow and I come here and I I've got the
elbow up here like this if he wants to
keep that elbow high and I can feel that
I kind of taking his balance a little
bit I get eek mul right so e mult comes
from that attempting to get EDI and the
EDI doesn't come off CU he's bending his
elbow to try and catch me and then when
he does that I shoot through and I can
get the uh EO multe all right now if I
stop that elbow from bending here or I
can't EO ult him then I can shoot
through here and get the true EDI all
right now if I wanted to just do
something right so and and I think this
is kind of outside the regular context
of iido not that it's wrong but it's
just I just want to get him so after I
shoot that I can do a really basic kind
of Ed Minag which is to grab him here
and pull him off and why I say that's
not really in the iido context that I
believe exists is because it's doing
something extra that you maybe don't
have to do however I'll would also say
that it's not truly out of the context
because the there could be a reason I
need to pull him down there multiple
attackers if this guy hits the ground
then that gives me more autonomy with
other people so there there are reasons
that it could could exist but I'm I'm
I'm saying that that would just be a
choice I made so I came back here and I
grab him and I want to pull him down
okay now another eating Minag can come
off of that though however that as I
enter in Josh is right behind me right
so he's turning right behind me right
behind me and if I allow that to happen
I'm going to get in a bad bad way right
so what happens is as I feel him doing
that I shoot my arm across and look as
he's coming to towards me I keep going
behind him right so this is the true Ed
Minag like you see in uh uh like the II
Kai style right where we make this
little circle and a lot of people like
to talk about like show them your
perspective and I show him the dojo as I
see it and then I do my technique right
and that's that's a big thing that
people like to talk about you know and
it's not my my jam but I understand why
people do like to talk about it but all
that's happening is as I go back here
he's chasing me and so I want to keep
staying behind him so I move towards him
and keep my arm up and that locks his p
in place and it makes it real real hard
for him to come to get me and that's
like the really katti flowy eag that
comes because he's chasing me back there
right now that to me is distinguished
from something where I just go here and
I break his balance because I want to
pull him down and I come through and I
do the edim Minag so I'm trying to
explain a situational reason for the
idim Minag as opposed to I just choose
to inflict a technique upon him okay now
understand that when I'm going this way
he will try to stop me Me by either
shooting his arm high like this to come
around and catch me or shooting his arm
low like this to come around and catch
me right so his arm's either going to go
here or here if he can't bend it in the
middle right he can't bend it in the
middle because we get that EO so he's
going to sweep around either high or low
if I stay connected to him and he sweeps
High then I still get my eek mot in fact
I get it even better because he's really
lifting his arm up so I'll get it most
of the time so again why shanu Iko is so
important is because that situation
it'll come up again and again and again
in a lot of different little ways
okay if he sweeps it low we transition
into a whole new set of techniques and
so that will have to be our next video
is where he's stopping me from making
the EDI but you can see that my choice
to try to make EDI leads us to edag and
EOS multes again and again and again
because of what he's doing as a response
to my action if he didn't do anything
then I would just shoot through right so
if he has no reaction I'd just do that
and I would walk on to wherever I wanted
to go this way because that's apparently
the direction I wanted to go right so
that's the response is for the EDI next
time we'll talk about the transitions
out of failed Edis and failed sulto mois
both I'm Christopher Hines Joshua T my
salon McDaniel is behind that camera
right there and she is Saturday Night
Live and that was some real that was
some real stuff right there uh all right
we'll see you guys in the next video
[Music]